una conmemoración anual que se remonta A
1987 el Día Mundial sin tabaco fue
instaurado por los estados miembros de
la Organización Mundial de la Salud para
advertir al público de las enfermedades
y muertes evitables que causa esta
sustancia Según la OMS el consumo de
tabaco mata a más de 8 millones de
personas cada año aumenta
significativamente el riesgo de los
consumidores de desarrollar enfermedades
respiratorias y cardiovasculares así
como más de 20 tipos o subtipos
diferentes de cáncer la organización
también señala que el 80% de los
consumidores proceden de países de
ingresos bajos y medios y que la mayoría
de las muertes relacionadas con el
tabaco también proceden de estos países
el lema de la celebración de este año es
cultiva alimentos no tabaco la campaña
pretende animar a los gobiernos a que
dejen de financiar el cultivo de tabaco
y en su lugar apoyen los cultivos que
alimentan a millones de personas y es
que los recientes conflictos el impacto
económico de la pandemia y los efectos
del cambio climático han contribuido a
una crisis alimentaria mundial
hay más de 350 millones de personas con
problemas de hambre e inseguridad
alimentaria y muchos de los países donde
estos problemas son preocupantes son
también grandes economías productoras de
tabaco en África por ejemplo en los
últimos 15 años el cultivo de tabaco ha
aumentado casi un 20%
la OMS también subraya que cambiar el
tabaco por cultivos alimentarios
mejoraría los medios de subsistencia de
los cultivadores de tabaco ya que muchos
sufren problemas de salud debido a los
productos químicos nocivos que utilizan
para cultivarlo